a watch party for the joe lombardo
campaign has been going strong all night
let's now check in with victoria saha
who's been there throughout the evening
victoria
hazy news much of the room has now
cleared out but earlier today this room
was packed many people stuck around to
hear sheriff joe lombardo give his
victory speech he was very adamant about
not speaking too soon but his campaign
was confident they would get a victory
tonight they believe tonight was a start
to sheriff lombardo's way to the
governor's seat take a listen to what
sheriff lombardo had to say earlier
about his journey to get there and get
here and what's next
tonight is just a victory for our
campaign tonight is a win for nevada's
across the state
it's a win for parents and their
children's education
it's a win for us safer communities and
it's a win for small business owners
sheriff lamardo did continue his speech
by saying it doesn't matter which party
you belong to but he did say nevada
comes first reporting live tonight
victoria zaha live local now